hello and welcome to this video this is
f viana okay so sticking with my real
guns for the first game yeah first game
i'm recording in this not that long
session that i'm planning but um yeah
let's go for a game metin do a warm-up
or anything and see what happens okay so
mm can't the italian game sir oh it
feels slightly annoyed and supporting
place that it is just so extremely solid
you can do very very little with black
again said okay now I have some hope so
again this untimely age 3 giving me g5g
for definitely um strike with this but
first i need to i have everything
correctly set up let's say night BD to
g5 will come like immediately
this should be three years of course
possible yeah this is always one of
those options where black is not going
to have much activity going without this
Bishop I can still play g5 it's this is
a bit on the on the risky side down yeah
otherwise I probably fall asleep so
let's do it and you can Castle play with
no rookie aid but should be six trade or
bishops and go on but it's not very
exciting yeah you should take on a 70 I
think I'm just placing my rook it's not
the only way it can also play that
Pikachu or something d 4 is also an
interesting idea after my g5 trying to
open up in the center i'll stop the
spree move the horse looks extremely
silly Jeff the head rook somehow in
midair yes okay
the other said in this version with
Bishop e3 being played that g5 business
is somewhat dicey because he has a very
stable center and gather d4 might come
okay we'll see I still I still think
this is a interesting interesting plane
so what now I can take I would like to
play night Jeff form so I'm going to
take and now bring the night over that
also allows Queen to f6 in some cases ok
he looks at my roof one problem is of
course I cannot cancel long anymore
that's a bit of a shame but as I said
this is in the Broadway after Bishop e3
this g5 plan is some somewhat
questionable but it was played to get
two more interesting position so here ya
Queen f6 was my original thought yeah I
think I still go forward Bishop g5 or
Bishop a form are definitely somewhat
irritating now I think if I if it
actually would be able to Castle long
this isn't all that bad or that wouldn't
wouldn't be all that bad but of course
there was room a seven I had to keep
showing his home
yeah we could she ate its kind of that
most obvious move that it doesn't really
threaten something yet but it's always
unnerving this kind of look yeah Brooke
occupying the half-open file so um
what's a possible way of getting pieces
into play group g4 is an idea while I
can move the Queen night back to G form
so it doesn't look doesn't feel very
convincing and I can theoretically
speaking play Knight to f4 if he takes
Queen g6 i think is winning for me but
it doesn't have to take of course
absolutely not ok yeah that one's in
tonight eh 449 f5 and maybe I'll put
this here took too long down one thing I
had in my favor was the time and now he
is it's even there ok good move good
move yeah at the city looking at work
now right ok night edge for is not
happening
and that f4 now also doesn't work if I
retreat a minute that it looks
completely silly lab should be one was a
strangled yeah okay look Jeff one
probably was quite stupid
you know can you somehow remove this
night with tempo on my night night eh
form but this hangs t4 and I have
neither fossa that's not I mean look G
fall back looks he leave it it's is he
having some good move now I mean move
might look silly and wasn't well thought
out but it's not clear that always has
to be terrible chart our rocks here he
takes very long time of course the King
looks strange on this outlet can see an
alternative kinky seven looks even worse
ok so sorry I should have gone to g7 set
of GH I can check a half no relax my
hair for the bloody King yeah I have no
Queen d6 unfortunately yeah but I have
to check check
yeah when I have to take but now I'm
lost right out here i was thinking
crudely sick still but night takes them
and he's going to going to kill me now
check what it unnecessary loss I don't
think the position was all that bad
check okay fatigue is going at 4i yes
show me czech czech animated is got the
rook here's the thing rook f1 is the
thing and then queen g3 is an act icky
form edge to stores from some kind of
checkmate Jack see no it doesn't see you
made the shack that's cute and I'm
probably winning on time check check
check why am i down long time I don't
understand this check check black
forfeits on time I mean I was like I had
a million minutes why was a below one
time all of a sudden I didn't understand
anything you ah yeah okay well this idea
with em with g5 is really questionable
if the bishops can be traded and this is
just genuinely good yeah the bishop he
is a strong attacking piece and I genji
for quickly after this it is really very
risky normal canceling would be evil to
be a good choice yeah the problem is
simply that you you get this
Luke misplaced and then you take far
longer time until you have things
somewhat coordinated now fishin t1
Angela that's all kind of i mean the
Angelus is not that pessimistic it gives
widen edge of course but only 0.7 yeah
and here here i'm lost them could have
taken you five already but digitech it's
just too strong check there were certain
design kind of check some kind of mates
of chapel check check yeah here is there
no mate the engine queen e 3 is plus
five but it doesn't give a direct made
funny enough with that crazy king check
and this turns everything around yeah by
now i was down on time I didn't really
realize that i was always ahead on the
clock in this game but it took a long
time to kind of chili so clever and
sadly lost check check check china and
this was just this typical senseless
move move move move yeah so this opening
probably shouldn't be repeated it's too
risky and disk in this particular form
okay well thanks for watching